Jesus became flesh to pay a human debt
scriptures are qu quite
clear Ezekiel 18 ver4 Ezekiel
18:20 the soul that sins shall
die if you sin you die die
physically and then if you read Romans
6:23 for the wages of sin is death right
the wages of sin is death but the gift
of God is everlasting life through Jesus
Christ Our
Lord okay you with me
there you with me there you
listening so if you sin you die if you
sin you
die all right now watch here so Jesus
knew that we cannot pay our debt and
therefore our death would be
permanent our death would be permanent
now
watch so the Lord knew he alone and only
he could pay our
debt pay our debt I need you to listen
here I need you to
listen all right please listen Holy
Spirit increase our numbers listen then
I'm going to go to Abraham Isaac and
Jacob and then I'll open up in Q&A
challenges the Lord knew knew he alone
could pay the debt but if the debt is
paid let's see if you're listening then
that means the debt is canceled right if
I ow a debt and I pay it it's cancelled
correct I need feedback this is a class
let the spirit
teach all right now watch this Chrystal
everyone I'm you're gonna see so if I
owe a debt and it's paid it's canceled
now if Jesus pays our debt by dying a
human death and because he's God that
debt
covers all our sins because the payment
is of infinite value because Jesus as
God a Divine person is infinite in his
value that's why it is heresy to say
Christ became a human person okay let me
explain to you the heresy if you say
Christ a Divine person who has infinite
value becomes a human
person that is blasphemy because that
means he changed from a Divine person a
human person something he cannot do
because God cannot seese being a Divine
person right but if he's a human person
then that makes him limited if he's a
human person he's Limited in his
value but if he's a Divine person and
doesn't stop being a Divine person then
as God being a Divine person his value
is infinite so as a Divine person he
becomes human and as a Divine person he
dies a human death but because it's a
Divine person who died a human death
that makes the value infinite in worth
you with me
there you with me
there if he's a human person his payment
is limited but if it's God a Divine
person who doesn't stop being God who
becomes human to experience a human
death because that's the only death he
could experience a human death then he
being God offering his life dying human
death is not
presenting an offering that's infinite
in
value now if the debt is paid that means
the debt is canceled
right if the debt is
paid the debt is cancelled right
okay so if the human debt is
death and Jesus Paid your debt that
means God will cancel
what Jesus Paid our debt by dying a
human death but if God accepts the
payment that means death is cancelled
right that means now death is
cancelled with me there
the debt he paid is dying a human death
because the soul that sins shall die he
paid it now if God accepts the payment
that means the debt is canel that means
death has to be canceled all right well
if death is cancelled that means Christ
cannot stay dead because if he stayed
dead that means the payment wasn't
accepted the debt was wasn't
cancelled but by rising from the dead
that was the proof God accepted his
payment the dead is cancelled which
means death is
cancelled in other words the
resurrection is the
inevitable outcome of Jesus's payment if
it's accepted he died the human debt to
cancel the human debt but that human
debt is death that means death is
canceled which means he had to be raised
physically you see why the physical
Resurrection necessary but here's what
you may not get need you to listen did
Jesus know that if he becomes flesh and
dies the debt will be cancelled yes did
Jesus know that if debt was cancelled
that means death is cancelled yes did
Jesus know that means that he would then
have to rise in that physical body body
continue to exist in that physical body
continue being a man with a physical
body that's now deathless yes does that
mean Jesus knew that the consequence of
his action means he would then remain a
man forever and not stop being a man yes
he knew that did he know that meant that
he'd always have a physical body and
could never get rid of that physical
body yes and he did it anyway yes
now do you understand what that means
Jesus knew he would not stop being a
man that means Jesus goes from being God
who didn't have a human
nature who didn't have a physical body
to then becoming flesh and knowing he
would remain in that flesh remain with a
physical body and never stop being
man and that's what he paid and you know
what that also means that means Jesus
forever has that physical body with the
holes in his hands and
side here it
is and he paid that price here it
is here it
is that's the price he paid John 20
24-29 but Thomas one of the 12 called
dimus was not with them when Jesus came
so the other disciples were saying to
him we have seen the Lord but he said to
them unless I see in his hands did you
catch it see Thomas as a Jew knew what
Resurrection meant there is no
resurrection that doesn't involve the
body well if he's been raised physically
that means that physical body that been
nailed there'll still be holes of the
nails in his
hands and there'll still be a hole in
his side from the soldier piercing his
side and put my finger into the place of
the nails and I put my hand into his
side I will not believe because there's
no Resurrection that's not bodily and if
you're telling him he's been raised that
means he's in that body with the holes
still intact now watch look at the price
that Jesus
Paid look at the price that Jesus Paid
and after eight days his disciples were
again inside and Thomas with them Jesus
came the doors having been shut and
stood in their midst and said peace be
with you then he said to Thomas bring
your finger and see my hands bring your
hand here and put it into my side wait
so Jesus had the physical hands with the
holes in his
hands yeah and Jesus had a physical body
with the hole in his side
yeah Thomas answer said to him my Lord
and my God then he saw and he believed
you truly are my Lord and my God so you
notice Jesus is a man with that physical
body with the whole still intact so he's
now a glorified man with a body that's
Immortal but he's more than a man he's
our Lord in God now look what Jesus says
Jesus said to him because you have seen
me you have belied blessed are those who
do not see and yet believe you see
it filthy
scum you see the price he paid you
understand what that
means this is the price that Jesus
Paid you will never understand the depth
of Jesus's love his infinite love and
what he chose to do and the sacrifice he
chose to make because of his infinite
love for
us yes he's in the flesh
brother no that's doesn't apply to us
then Paul take it easy you're not going
to have scars and wounds Jesus's scars
and wounds is a reminder of the price he
paid so take it
easy everyone got it
you got it
now Christ chose to become man knowing
he'd remain a man knowing as a man he'd
have a physical body and he would have
that physical body forever and never
cease to have that body knowing this is
the price you'd have to pay and he chose
to pay it anyway